you don't become what you want because
so much of wanting is about
living in the space of what you don't
have
lack of belief is the world's number one
problem the real spiritual practice is
to like
live from within and not let the world
divine who you are but you do that for
yourself that's that's the hardest work
rise and shine it's espresso time hey
it's evan carmichael and i am not a
morning person
but when you start your day with a
powerful routine that inspires you like
watching one of these videos it can
change your life so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee know
that i believe in you and get ready for
a shot of espresso from oprah winfrey
[Music]
many of you
as i have been as i am are where you are
in your life based upon what you believe
and it's not just what you think you
believe on the surface it's also your
shadow beliefs that are holding you back
from moving into the life that you
believe
you deserve what i know is if you're not
looking at the shadows if you're not
looking at what is
subconsciously running through the tape
in your mind telling yourself you're not
good enough you're not worthy enough
you're not smart enough you're not
enough
which is a tape that's playing for a lot
of people
if you're not conscious of that then you
end up acting out of that belief system
and not out of what you know to be the
truest or want to be the truest for
yourself
you don't become what you want because
so much of wanting is about
living in the space of what you don't
have that's why jim carrey's story is so
powerful because he started to act as
though he already had it he would go up
to mulholland drive he would drive away
saying thinking i already have those
things i just haven't accessed them as
yet i believe those things are going to
come to me and i'm going to act like
they are so i'm going to move forward in
my life in order to
draw that to myself in such a way that
my actions are in alignment with what i
say
i believe
so if you start to think about that
really why are you where you are in your
life the choices that you have made
have been because of what you believe to
be true for yourself lack of belief is
the world's number one problem i put it
in my bios and all my social media
accounts i put it in my official bio and
people introduced me lack of belief
is the world's number one problem
you have what i call michael jordan
level genius that's something you you
you hello hi you you're a genius at
something you're genius you are the best
in the world
at something
you are
and it's not what your parents did and
that's not what your friends did and
some you went to school for
but you
can be
the greatest
in the world of something
the problem is you don't believe that
one that that's possible like nah some
days you might but not consistently
and two you don't believe that you can
get there
and so you
don't and we have these moments these
these hits of inspiration
and then it falls back down
and what i'm trying to do is this fight
that both for myself
i don't fully believe in myself to hit
the next level
and then and then for you for the world
to spread
because i think
if everybody could live their michael
jordan level genius what an amazing
world to be in it doesn't mean everybody
needs to be an entrepreneur but
everybody's got michael jordan level
genius or something
and it wasn't possible in the past to
actually live that life you know think
about how old you are right now think
about your parents
when your parents were your age
and what year was it when your parents
were your age what year was it the
opportunities available
to your parents
when they were your age were drastically
different it wasn't possible for them
my parents how old am i now i'm 41.
when i started my youtube channel
i was 29.
[Music]
when my parents were 29
or 41 youtube didn't exist
you had to be crazy to be an
entrepreneur
it was just so much harder
now it's it's all possible
and it's only getting easier
it's only getting easier to find more
role models to find more access
it's only getting easier
but it starts with you believing that is
possible
so
in today's video i want to i want to
share
the three ways to get more belief
people ask me i mean belief is important
it's not my shirt
believe
how do you get more belief
we're going to break it down today to
help you do it because it's easy to say
well believe in yourself believe in
yourself okay but how
inspiration
courage
and consistency
inspiration
courage and consistency
so inspiration
is being around the things that inspire
you to believe in yourself more that
could be these videos yeah that could be
other videos that could be
podcasts and books that could be friends
that could be communities or groups like
movement makers
what inspires you and you've already
you've already felt belief when did you
feel the most belief in yourself and
what you're capable of what were you
doing who were you around where were you
what were you listening to or watching
or reading
and then finding some kind of
consistent source to have that in your
life you need to be
regularly inspired
to believe in yourself more to believe
in what could happen believe in what
could be what you can create what helps
you believe in yourself more
when were those moments so some people
say that inspiration is not enough and
they're right it's not you know
motivation motivation alone is not
enough
you have to do something
what's the point of watching a video
like this
it's not just to get hyped up and
inspired it's to do something why in
every video why do i say what's your
plan of action write down the comments
below what's your plan of action i wanna
know what are you gonna do
your life doesn't change until you do
but the point of watching a video like
this the point of getting inspired the
point of getting motivated
leads you to the second point which is
courage
inspiration needs to lead to courage
inspiration alone is a life unfulfilled
courage
to then take the action
watching a video like this the hope is
that it gets you inspired enough
to believe in yourself even if for a
moment guys even if only for a moment
you don't need to have belief all day
long you just need that moment of belief
to give you the courage to do something
to commit to somebody to make that video
to send that email to make that phone
call
to start
it's the courage to start
but without the inspiration you won't
have the courage because the idea is too
big
you've got this big goal big dream big
plan for yourself you're going to feel
like it's impossible so you never start
you don't summon the courage because you
weren't inspired
so inspiration step number one which
leads to the courage to actually do
something which is important why you
don't leave that moment nina's here hey
nina we love you
the courage to start something
right whenever you feel
inspired and empowered motivated
amazing the best you can do is take
immediate action immediate action
on your goals
i believe that when you are feeling
inspired courageous motivated etc
whatever ideas come to you are actually
the best ideas for you have you ever
ever had you ever gone to a conference
you ever watched the video you got so
inspired i'm gonna do this i believe
that that idea
is the best thing for you it's the best
thing for
you and then you fall back down to
normal your head takes over keeps you
scared safe protected
and you don't do it
and we just spike between these moments
of inspiration
the best thing to do is to take some
kind of immediate action after watching
a video that gets you hyped up do
something after going to a conference it
gets you hyped up do something after
having a conversation with with a friend
that gets you inspired do something do
something do something do something do
something the inspiration the only value
and the inspiration is yes uh you know
an afternoon or an evening or a couple
hours of feeling good
but it's the doing something it's the
the courage
that leads you to taking some kind of
action to make your life change
you have to do something immediate
action when you're feeling inspired
the third part so inspiration
leads to the courage
to do something to then consistency
consistent action will lead you
to your dream life
the goals you want
the impact you want to have
it'll be consistently doing these things
the difference between an achiever and a
high achiever is the consistent
willingness to do the thing when it's
hard
the consistent willingness to show up
when it's hard
because otherwise you just
jump between starting and stopping and
starting and stopping and starting to
stop and you get inspired most people
get inspired a lot great inspired it's
about inspired some people will take
irregular action
every now and then you'll take some kind
of action and then the highest of the
high achievers they take consistent
action
and so you need to make this a part of
your daily routine where it's every day
you watch a video like this every day
you're part of a community like mover
makers every day you're reading a book
or podcast something that's filling you
up to make you feel inspired
the inspiration leads to that moment of
courage we're going to say yes to
yourself and say yes to that project and
make that phone call or make that video
do some kind of action
not just research your plan or watch
another video but do something
and then every single day
do that
make it a consistent part of your daily
routine
if you did that your life
in a year will look dramatically
different it just will it just has to
imagine if you woke up every day
not expecting to feel inspired because
you won't i don't wake up feeling
inspired every day but you're going to
wake up
do the thing that creates inspiration
for you that then leads to some kind of
courageous action and then you're
consistent doing that could you imagine
if every day for the next year you did
that every day for the next year you
woke up you got inspired you took
courageous action
and you did that consistently for a year
you won't recognize your life it'll be
dramatically different than where you
are right now
make the change
that's how you start to have more belief
in yourself believe that it's possible
believe that you can believe that it
will work out
because
belief says nina because you deserve it
timo deserves it he looks tired nina
deserves it
the world deserves it
your family deserves it
it's time to start showing up
believe
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the sign says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action
of when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else that jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate yeah
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief the sign
says it can take up to
254 days of consecutive action for the
habit to stick that's what i want for
you so i've designed a custom free
program we're going to send you an
unlisted video for the next 254 days to
shift your confidence and belief
forward
the link to join is in the description
below it was very difficult for me to
figure out where my boundaries were
because i'd grown up poor and didn't
have anything your real work
is to figure out
where your power base is become so
skilled
so vigilant so flat out
fantastic
at what you do
that your talent cannot be dismissed
what about something that you feel like
you've personally achieved or overcome
is there something that you are
especially proud of yourself for yeah
i'm especially proud of myself for not
uh living in the world of comparisons
you know
uh years ago when i pulled out that
wagon of fat i was actually comparing
myself to everybody else or what i
thought you're supposed to look like or
what size you're supposed to be so i've
now reached the point where i'm really
okay
exactly where i am and that's you know
it's taken me a lifetime practically to
figure that out and being okay exactly
where you are because preparing is a
dangerous it's so hard because we are in
the world of insta comparison you know
and so
the real spiritual practice is to like
live from within and not let the world
divine who you are but you
do that for yourself that's that's the
hardest work i'm going to continue
developing shows that speak uh
to
the humanity of people in a way that
makes them want to
live better and do better
and
that exalts their
their their victories and lets them know
that they are important and meaningful
in the world you know i would have to
say that
every day david that show was such a it
was like therapy for me kind of like now
every day this show was
i paid attention so i've never been to a
therapist but i i i paid attention all
those days on the show and i made
therapy acceptable for a lot of people
who thought ah not me not so
one of the things i started to get
uh
around
mid to late no no mid to late 90s is
that everybody that i had on the show at
the end of the show would say something
to me like
um
was that okay was that okay how was that
was that okay
at the end of the interview
and i started to then track it it didn't
matter if it was um i i i had gone and
done a show where i was in um
a prison i was interviewing a father
who
was in jail for life for murdering his
twin daughters and at the end of the
interview even behind bars he said to me
is that okay
how'd i do
and barack obama said it when he sat in
the chair the first time and george bush
said it beyonce said it at the end of
she taught me how to talk and then said
is that okay
so that's an acquired skill do they yes
working thing but this is what i learned
uh sitting in that chair for 25 years
that at the end of the day
whether you are
interviewing me or i get to interview
you
whatever your profession is
wherever you are in your life in your
relationships
every person that you encounter every
experience the person wants to know
was that okay
was that okay
and what i started to hear was that what
people are really saying is did you hear
me
did you hear me
and did what i say mean anything to you
and so i started to listen
with that in mind with that intention of
validating that your being here
you're speaking to me you're taking the
time to do this with me is important
because you matter and that's true for
everybody who's watching or listening
that every argument that you ever have
every encounter the person just wants to
know did you hear me did you see me and
did i say anything
there's a bigger dream waiting for you
just waiting
for you
to step into it
to step into it your life is big
your life is huge and we spend so much
time
wanting to be in somebody else's life
and you don't get honored
you don't get revered you don't get
celebrating wanting what somebody else
has
because
that which created you divine
intelligence that dreamed you from
before your ancestors ever knew
they would become your ancestors that
which dreamed the seed of you
wants you to know how
special how wondrous how mysterious how
complex how glorious how phenomenal you
are
and you get no credit
messing in somebody else's territory
or trying to have
power
over something you have no control
another one of my favorite teachings is
the wizard of oz
when the wicked which is the west says
go away from here because you don't have
any power here you have no power in any
territory other than your own
oh but you are the master of that
you get to be the master of your own
fate you get to be the captain of your
own soul and if you just manage that
if you just took care of your territory
all the glorious glorious glorious
wondrous
wondrous opportunities and possibilities
that are waiting for you so the question
is what are you resisting
what are you pushing against
what are you not allowing what are you
blocking because you have this idea of
who and what you're supposed to be
instead of
leaning into the dream that's already
been created and waiting for you it's
waiting for you and the second i mean it
doesn't it's an instant thing it's a
shift in the way you see yourself and
the power from which you have come
so the angel network i've been on the
air for
a long time
but it was the angel network that
actually focused my internal gps it
helped me to decide that i wasn't just
gonna be on tv every day
but that the goal of my shows my
interviews my business my philanthropy
all of it whatever ventures i might
pursue would be to make clear
that
what unites us
is ultimately far more redeeming and
compelling than anything that separates
me because what it become clear to me
and i want you to know it isn't always
clear in the beginning because as i said
i've been on television since i was 19
years old
but around 94 i got really clear so
don't expect the clarity to come all at
once to know your purpose right away
but what became clear to me was that i
was here
on earth to use television and not be
used by it
to use television to illuminate the
transcendent power
of our better angels
so
this angel network it didn't just change
the lives of those who were helped but
the lives of those who also did the
helping
it reminded us that no matter who we are
or what we look like or what we may
believe it is both possible
and more importantly it becomes powerful
to come together in common purpose and
common effort you will find true success
and happiness
if you have only one goal there really
is only one and that is this
to fulfill
the highest
most truthful
expression of yourself
as a human being
you want to max out your humanity
by using your energy to lift yourself up
your family and the people around you
theologian howard thurman said it best
he said
don't ask yourself what the world needs
ask yourself what makes you come alive
and then go do that
because what the world needs is people
who have come alive
the world needs
people like michael stahlzenberg from
fort lauderdale when michael was just
eight years old michael nearly died from
a bacterial infection that caused him
both of his hands and both of his feet
and in an instant this vibrant little
boy became a quadruple amputee
and his life
was changed forever
but in losing who he once was
michael discovered who he wanted to be
he refused to sit in that wheelchair all
day and feel sorry for himself so with
prosthetics he learned to walk
and run and play again
he joined his middle school lacrosse
team and last month when he learned that
so many victims of the boston marathon
bombing would become new amputees
michael decided to banish that darkness
with light michael and his brother
harris created mikeysrun.com
to raise one million dollars for other
amputees
by the time harris runs the 2014 boston
marathon
more than a thousand miles away from
here
these two young brothers
are bringing people together to support
this boston community the way their
community came together to support
michael
and when this 13 year old man was asked
about his fellow amputees he said this
first
they will be sad
they're losing something
they will never get back
and that's scary
i was scared
but they'll be okay
they just don't know that yet
we might not always know it
we might not always see it or hear it
on the news
or even feel it in our daily lives but i
have faith
that no matter what
class of 2013
you will be okay
and you will make sure our country is
okay
i have faith because of that
nine-year-old girl who went out and
collected the change
i have faith because of david and
francine wheeler i have faith because of
michael and harris stolzenberg and i
have faith because of you the network of
angels sitting here today one of them
khadijah williams who came to harvard
four years
ago khadijah had attended 12 schools in
12 years
living out of garbage bags
amongst pimps and prostitutes and drug
dealers
homeless
going into department stores walmart in
the morning to bathe herself so that she
wouldn't smell in front of her
classmates
and today she graduates as a member of
the harvard class
of 2013. i had a job until i could
figure out what it was really what that
gave my life its purpose and meaning
and um
i had gotten demoted in my job in
baltimore as an anchor woman because
as they hired me and then they decided i
was the wrong color
and i was the wrong size and i was the
wrong you know i had lots of problems
and they were trying to take me off the
air
and um
i was making 22 000 a year i thought i
was in heaven because i was making my
age and my dream at the time was gail
and i used to say can you imagine if
you're 40 and you're making 40 000.
that'd be it
so um
uh that was as big as my dream was just
to make my age
and then i did this they they put me on
a talk show one morning because
they didn't know what to do with me
and and i was interviewing the carvel
ice cream man it was a local talk show
and
um
benny from um
benny who was mrs
chancellor's
uh butler or something on all my
children anyway my soap opera star who
wasn't the lead star remember benny
benny and the carvel ice cream men
that's how i cut my teeth and i finished
that show so it's not about the the
stars themselves or whoever the guests
were but i felt like this is what i'm
supposed to do
all these years have been misplaced in
news because i couldn't relate to news i
was a news reporter and i'd be out on
the stories and i'd be crying with the
people
and i felt that i was exploiting the
people with news i couldn't
you know put a microphone in people's
face when they were going through
tragedies and stuff i just was so
emotional i was always getting little
notes from my boss about cut that out
you need to stop so but the moment i did
that talk show i felt like oh
i can be myself
and that was august 14th 1978. and that
was the beginning of fulfilling the
calling and so since that time
since that time august 14th 1978 i've
never had a problem with energy now when
i was working in news i used to be
exhausted all the time because i just
exhausted all the time because i hated
it
and the reason i didn't quit is because
i'm not a quitter number one and because
my father was like better not quit that
job you're making 22 000 a year
who's gonna play a black woman between
two thousand dollars a year you're never
gonna make make that kind of money again
you better save half of it so
i i was reluctant to quit and think
about doing something else because i
thought okay everybody wants to be an
anchor woman at the time that was like
supposedly a big deal being an anchor
woman so i thought okay i won't i'll
just stay with this until i can figure
out what is the best thing to do
and interestingly enough i was applying
for what i wanted to do
i felt like i needed to be able to talk
and at the time the only thing that was
available was um
was uh like good morning america or
today show so i called up this agent and
i asked if he would accept my tape
because i wanted to be like a substitute
for brian gumbel and he said to me
there was only going to be one bryant
gumbel and so
there wasn't going to be another one
that they weren't going to let another
black person on that show he said that
to me
and um
interestingly enough he called me last
week because somebody else mentions it
to say he never said it but he did say
it and i said to him you know what if
you're ever told that you never forget
it if somebody ever says to you if
you're ever rejected in that way you
never ever ever forget it i said but
it's okay i did okay you did okay
it's all right but the answer to your
question is if you can find what is your
passion if you find what you love you
never get tired or if you do get tired
if you you're fueled by the energy of
your work so i know that i'm doing
exactly what i'm supposed to be doing at
this time
i also know that what this this show can
do
in terms of being
a voice and changing the world it's just
the beginning of what this show can do
it's fun to do things like this
but uh and it's necessary to do things
like this in order to be able to do the
bigger grander things to change what
happens to to the face of children in
africa for example what happens to
education with kids in in this country
so i believe that
that what has happened to me is really
the beginning
of the greater passion to come
but if you find out what you're supposed
to do and you know what you're supposed
to do by how it feels
you know people wait on the voice of god
to be some the moses in burning bush i
think that was only bible talk
you know because he doesn't come to
burning bushes for people he comes
through your heart
he speaks through your heart through
your feelings and so you know what if
you're doing the right thing if it feels
like it's right to you and when you hit
the thing that feels right when you know
it's the right thing you would you know
it's right because it gives you your
juice
and you know it's right because you
would do it for nothing
you would do it for nothing and find a
way to be able just to do it
in order to be able to continue
that's how you know you're doing what
you're supposed to be doing
nobody's journey is seamless or smooth
we all stumble we all have setbacks if
things go wrong you hit a dead end as
you will
it's just life's way of saying
time to change course
so ask every failure this is what i do
every failure every crisis every
difficult time i say what is this here
to teach me
and as soon as you get the lesson
you get to move on if you really get the
lesson you pass and you don't have to
repeat the class if you don't get the
lesson it shows up wearing another pair
of pants
or skirt
to give you some remedial work
and what i found is that difficulties
come when you don't pay attention to
life's whisper
because life always whispers to you
first first and if you ignore the
whisper sooner or later you'll get a
scream
whatever you resist persists but if you
ask the right question not why is this
happening but what is this here to teach
me what is this here to teach me it puts
you in the place and space to get the
lesson you need my friend ed cartoli
uh who's written this wonderful book
uh called a new earth
that's all about letting the awareness
of who you are stimulate everything that
you do he puts it like this he says
don't react against a bad situation
merge with that situation instead and
the solution will arise from the
challenge
because surrendering yourself doesn't
mean giving up it means acting with
responsibility
okay
many of you know that as president
hennessey said i started this school
in africa
and
i founded the school where i'm trying to
give south african girls a shot at a
future like yours stanford
and i spent five years making sure that
school would be as beautiful as the
students
i wanted every girl to feel her worth
reflected in her surroundings so i
checked every blueprint
i picked every pillow
i was looking at the grout in between
the bricks i knew every thread count of
the sheets i chose every girl from the
villages from nine provinces and yet
last fall i was faced with a crisis i'd
never anticipated i was told that one of
the dorm matrons was suspected of sexual
abuse
well that was as you can imagine
devastating news
first i cried actually i sobbed for
about a half an hour
and then i said let's get to it that's
all you get is a half an hour you need
to focus on the now
what you need to do now so i contacted a
child trauma specialist i put together a
team of investigators i made sure the
girls had counseling and support and
gail and i got on a plane and flew to
south africa and the whole time i kept
asking that question
what is this here to teach me
and as difficult as that experience has
been
i got a lot of lessons
i understand now the mistakes i made
because i
had been paying attention to all of the
wrong things
i built that school from the outside in
when what really mattered was the inside
out so it's a lesson that applies to all
of our lives as a whole what matters
most is what's inside what matters most
is the sense of
integrity of quality and beauty i got
that lesson and what i know is is that
the girls came away with something too
they've emerged from this more resilient
and knowing that their voices
have power i did this at the end of my
uh
show i did my favorite guest of all
times that's hard to do out of
literally
thousands and thousands they supposedly
estimated that there's like 35 000
people i interviewed over the years but
there was one woman out of all the
celebrities out of all of the
famous non-famous infamous people one
woman
who was she her name is tarai trent
listen to the story
i'm going to try to shorten it for you
guys okay tara right trent born and
raised in a village in zimbabwe 11 years
old she's doing her brother's homework
she wants to go to school her father
says no you're a girl you have to
educate the boy yes that's right
that's right the boy has to go to school
you can't go to school so she starts
doing her brother's homework
she does his brother's homework he goes
to school he gets all a's on his
homework yet he doesn't know the answer
to the question the teacher comes to the
village to say what is going on here
this boy doesn't know the answers but
his homework's perfect she finds out
that tarai his younger sister is doing
his homework she begs the father to let
terrorize go to school the father says
no she can't go to school finally he
marries her off she marries at 11 and a
half years old she gets married she has
three children by the time she's 18
years old a woman comes to the village
from an ngo heifer international and
asks what are your dreams this is going
to make me cry finally
ask her what are your dreams
this child has never thought about what
her dreams were she says write down your
dreams she writes down her dreams on a
piece of paper and she folds them in a
tin can and she buries them under a rock
the first dream was to be able to go to
the school and go to a school in the
united states of america
and get a college degree
she ends up
through some miracle of the ngo going to
the united states she gets a college
degree wow yes she gets a four-year
degree in three years terrorized trent
she goes back to the rock in zimbabwe
she writes her next goal on the piece of
paper she buries it under the rock she
writes i want to get a master's degree
she goes back to uni and said she gets a
master's degree by this time she now has
five children she's married to a man who
still beats her incredible she goes back
united states she gets her master's
degree after the master's degree she
goes back to the rock in zimbabwe she
writes down her final goal is to get a
doctorate degree and last year she
became dr tararai trent where did you
find it where did i find it um
i found
her
in the in the nicholas kristoff's book
called
uh
something the sky underneath the sky or
the guy nichol i found her in nicholas
christoph's book
and i was reading the story
i had nicholas kristoff on the show
nicholas kristoff the famous new york
times writer
and
she wasn't there she wasn't a part of
the ch i'm reading the story i can't
believe this book the story of this
woman as i'm reading the story
so when we go to do the show
the producers have nicholas kristoff on
they bring on other guests but this
woman isn't there i go how could you not
have her there so we tape another show
with nicholas kristoff we go back and go
find we're going to find that woman
terror right trent this time by this
time she's living in the united states
we followed her back to zimbabwe to the
rock
we pulled the tin can from underneath
the rock
and that is my favorite guest of all
time and the worst
um
i don't have a worst i don't have a
worse but the reason why she and as i
said this on my show the reason why tara
rai trent is my favorite guest of all
time is because she represents in that
one story of the little girl in a
village in zimbabwe who had a dream
and the heart and depth and discipline
to pursue it she represents everything i
tried to say in every show in 25 years
she literally through her life story
sums up the message that i was trying to
give to every single one of my viewers
you can
you can
keep trying
don't give up you have to believe you
have to believe close your eyes for a
moment will you please
and breathe with me just close your eyes
and if you will
put your thumb
to your middle finger
and gather your other fingers around and
let's
feel the vibration
and pulse of your personal energy as you
take three deep breaths with me
inhale
and as you exhale just feel
[Music]
the vibration
energy
blood pulsating
through
your body through you
and another inhale
and another inhale
ah
and keep your eyes closed
and let's just think about
this day
this day that you have been graced
to breathe
in and out
thousands of times
this day
where many of those breaths were taken
for granted you just expected the next
one to come
but the truth is there's no guarantee
that the next one comes
this day
how you started your day what your
thoughts were this morning
how you've carried yourself through this
day
how you've been allowed to have
encounters and experiences
some challenging
some more life enhancing
that push you forward another day
of being here on the planet earth
as a human
being
let's just think about that
after all you've been through
in this day alone
and the many days and years passed
how you got here to this
prestigious esteemed university
the choices you made
that have brought you to this day
open your heart
and quietly to yourself
say the only prayer
that's ever needed
thank you
thank you
thank you
you're still here
and you get another chance
this day
to do better and be better
another chance to become more
of who
you were created
and what you were created to fulfill
thank you everything you try to do is
already done so when i figured that out
oh what i'm putting out is what's coming
back let me get real clear about what it
is i'm putting out
real clear
so
i read a book about 1989 called seed of
the soul and in that book yerry zhukov
talked about
the laws
of
karma of
the laws of cause and effect the third
law of motion and in that book he talked
about how intention your intention
is always
one
with the law
meaning
before you even think about a thing you
have an intention for the thing
and that the intention is going to
determine the outcome
that's why the same people can go to the
same church service
and somebody walked down the aisle just
to be seen to put some money in
the
church
and somebody else who just goes and just
has a little bit to offer
the intention with which you give
the intention with which you serve
determines the outcome so when i figured
that out
i went whoa
i changed everything i did on my show
i called in the producers and i said
from this day forward i will no longer
be speaking to the kkk
i will no longer be speaking to people
who are fighting each other in a way
that it is damaging to the character of
myself and other people who watch from
this day forward i am only going to do
intentional television i know you all
understand better than most that real
progress requires
authentic
an authentic way of being
honesty and above all empathy
i have to say
that the single most important lesson i
learned in 25 years talking every single
day to people
was that there is a common denominator
in our human experience
most of us
i tell you we don't want to be divided
what we want the common denominator that
i found in every single interview is we
want to be validated
we want to be understood
i've done over
35
000 interviews in my career
and
as soon as that camera shuts off
everyone always turns to me and
inevitably in their own way asks this
question
was that okay
i heard it from president bush
i heard it from president obama
i've heard it from heroes and from
housewives i've heard it from victims
and perpetrators of crimes i even heard
it from beyonce and all of her beyonce
she finishes performing hands me the
microphone and says was that okay
friends and family yours enemies
strangers in every argument in every
encounter every exchange i will tell you
they all want to know one thing
was that okay
did you hear me
do you see me
did what i say mean anything to you
and even though this is the college
where facebook was born
my hope is that you will try to go out
and have more face-to-face conversations
with people you may disagree with
[Applause]
that you'll have
the the courage
to look them in the eye and hear their
point of view
and
help make sure that the speed and
distance
and anonymity of our world doesn't cause
us to lose our ability to stand in
somebody else's shoes and recognize all
that we share as a people this is
imperative for you as an individual and
for our success as a nation the way to
make movies is to do stuff that you love
because you know for 25 years i worked
on the oprah show and
uh steven will tell you that there were
day nights that i came home and i almost
you know it's hard to even like take off
my clothes because i knew i was going to
be getting up four hours later but i
never really felt exhausted
like depl i never i felt exhausted but i
never felt depleted so do the work that
comes straight from
the soul of you from your background
from stories that you've grown up with
from stories that bring you passion from
stories that you uh not just yearn to
tell
but that if you don't tell them they
won't get told and when you when you are
operating you know the single
the single greatest uh
wisdom i think i've ever received other
than
when people show you they are is that
the key to fulfillment success
happiness
contentment in life is when you align
your personality
with what your soul actually came to do
i believe everybody has a soul and has
you know their own personal
spiritual energy so when you can use
your personality to serve whatever that
thing is
you can't help but be successful so if
you do films that come from the interior
of your soul you do work you do art that
comes from the interior of you
it you cannot miss
it's only when you're doing stuff that
you think might make money you think it
may be
a hit or you think it may
uh bring you some level of attention or
success that isn't what does it i would
have to say that all of the great
wonderful experiences of my life that
have brought me to this moment have come
from working from the interior of myself
and so that's why it feels so authentic
because it it actually is
so when you do that you'll win
one of the things i started to get
uh
around
mid to late no no mid to late 90s is
that everybody that i had on the show at
the end of the show would say something
to me like
um
was that okay was that okay how was that
was that okay right at the end of the
interview
and i started to then track it it didn't
matter if it was um i i i had gone and
done a show where i was in um
a prison i was interviewing a father
who
was in jail for life for murdering his
twin daughters and at the end of the
interview even behind bars he said to me
is that okay
how'd i do
and barack obama said it when he sat in
the chair the first time and george bush
said it beyonce said it at the end of
she taught me how to twerk and then said
is that okay
so that's an acquired skill do they yes
working thing but this is what i learned
uh sitting in that chair for 25 years
that at the end of the day
whether you are
interviewing me or i get to interview
you
whatever your profession is
wherever you are in your life in your
relationships
every person that you encounter every
experience the person wants to know
was that okay
was that okay
and what i started to hear was that what
people are really saying is did you hear
me
did you hear me
and did what i say mean anything to you
and so i started to listen
with that in mind with that intention of
validating that your being here
you're speaking to me you're taking the
time to do this with me is important
because you matter and that's true for
everybody who's watching or listening
that every argument that you ever have
every encounter the person just wants to
know did you hear me did you see me and
did i say anything that mattered i went
through some tough times
after after i left the oprah show i made
a conscious decision
that i did not want to be sitting on tv
with the oprah show and y'all saying she
should have left that show
that show was really good two years ago
i made a conscious decision decision
that when i felt i had said
all that i could say
and the audience had heard it
that i would move on and that i would
not spend my life regretting or trying
to hold on to what used to be or hold on
to what i had so i dreamed this dream
of starting a network and in the
beginning it was it was a struggle
it was a struggle because
i didn't honestly goodness i did not
know what i was doing
i was trying to figure it out
i was trying to figure it out i thought
that the oprah show audience would
follow us to own then i realized y'all
didn't have cable
and if you had cable you did not have
the own package
[Applause]
so
so it took me a minute
and unlike most people who you get to
have your mistakes in private some don't
go right in your life you get to
talk about it in private if i make a
mistake it's on the cnn crawl
or the cnn news so when i was in the
climb and there were so many wonderful
owners i see churro action jackson here
there were so many wonderful owners
people who said oh we're going to stand
with you we're going to stand by you
thank you roland martin there were so
many people who said listen we believe
that this can happen
so i dreamed the dream
along with tyler perry who was my friend
who came to me and said tyler
tyler said i'm going to help you out
because tyler can go home and write a
script and direct it produce it and
shoot it
and do it for less money than anybody in
hollywood so we started with the
foundation of having have not
[Applause]
if loving you is wrong
love thy neighbor
mama hattie
and then i started to dream another
dream about
scripted television because in the
beginning i was told you couldn't do it
you couldn't do it didn't have enough
money to do it
and
i dreamed the dream
i read proverbs 11 28 that says those
who trust in their riches will fall but
the righteous will rise and thrive like
a green leaf
i first started making money and it was
you know my salary
or my earnings
were
published all over the place i mean the
first year i was like really did i make
that much money oh my god
um
it was very difficult for me to figure
out where my boundaries were
because i'd grown up poor and didn't
have anything
so it's easy when you don't have
anything and people ask you for money
they say i need 500 i don't have it
because i'm just trying to get my rent
paid
it's harder when your
multi-billion dollar salary is now in
the paper and you get a lot of friends
and cousins you didn't have before
so how do you set
boundaries for yourself i was having
trouble setting boundaries myself for
myself for even strangers people would
just show up at my door in chicago and
say oh bro i left my husband please help
me
and i would because she knows i haven't
so
don't try that now though okay
don't try that now i figured it out
so what i learned was is that
oh the reason why people keep showing up
is because my intention is to make them
think that i'm such a nice person
that
you can ask me for anything
you can get me to do anything i'm going
to say yes i'm going to say yes so when
stevie called me this time i thought i'd
try out my first no on stevie let's
start big
he wanted me to donate some money to a
charity and i didn't want to donate to
the charity
because
i have my own charities and i care about
a lot of people but the the problem is
when you you have money everybody thinks
you just want to give to everything so
every letter i ever get starts with we
know you love the children
yes i do love the children but somebody
else is going to have to help the
children
so i said to stevie uh i said to stevie
no
um
as a person who has that disease to
please i was waiting for him then just
to say
i will never speak to you again
i will never call you i will never sing
a song for you
and he didn't he just said okay
okay
okay it's okay he said okay check you
later
and
[Music]
what i learned from that is
many times you will have angst and worry
about things
and
put yourself in a state like someone
said this morning because their phone
went off they were mortified over a
phone i said really
you will put yourself in a state when
the other person really isn't even
thinking about you
so
learning that i could specifically
determine for myself what the boundaries
were for me
what i wanted to do
give my money give my time give of my
service to who i wanted to give it to
when i did that i get to make that
decision and just because you get a
hundred requests a week doesn't mean you
have to try to fulfill all of that just
because you have all of these demands on
your time and on you doesn't mean that
you
have to say yes you get to decide
because you're the master of your fate
the captain of your soul as william
ernest henley said in invictus and
understanding that really changed the
meaning of my life in that i was not
no longer driven by what
other people wanted me to do
but took charge of my own destiny making
choices based upon what do i feel
is the next right move for me everybody
works hard
and everybody has their own dreams
there is
there was a time
where i used to spend a lot of energy
wanting things
wanting things
of course it's easy for me to say oh
things don't define you because i got a
lot of things things nice i like them
but this is what i learned
when you can surrender to the dream
you get to live in the space of the
higher power
you get to live in the space
that you purposefully have come to earth
to claim for yourself so
around
1984 i was sitting in bed one morning
uh sunday morning should have been in
church but i wouldn't
i was reading
the new york times review of the color
purple and i thought whoa this sounds
like a really great book i got out of
bed in my pajamas put on my galoshes
and
went to the store to get the copy of the
color purple
i read the color purple in one afternoon
got
went back to the bookstore bought every
book of the color purple i took the
books to the office and i said to
everybody y'all got to read this book oh
my god you got to read this book color
purple i needed a book club i didn't
have one
so i pass out the book to everybody i
knew please read the color purple read
the color purple
then i start to hear
that somebody's going to do a movie
about the color purple but i don't know
anybody in the movie business by this
time i was on am chicago i don't know
anybody i start praying to god god
please help me find a way to get into
color purple
i say jesus i don't even have to have a
speaking part
i will be because i went to the movies
and i saw on the movie credits
at the last credit there's something
called best boy
so i said jesus if you just let me be
best girl
that'll be all right by me i can be best
girl
i can carry the script i can help the
people with the water i can do whatever
so i start praying for the color purple
as
as
divine law would have it quincy jones
comes to chicago
and he is in chicago for one half of a
day
because somebody has filed a suit
against michael jackson claiming that
billie jean was their lover and that's
not his song
so quincy had taken the red eye to
chicago
he was in his hotel room
he was coming out of the shower
and the television in his hotel room is
on am chicago
there sits
little chubby me
with my jared curl
on am chicago
quincy jones tells ruben cannon the
casting agent i think i found sophia so
i get a call
from ruben cannon who says i'm calling
about a movie
it's called moon song
would you be interested to come and
audition and i say i have not been
praying for moon song
i had not been playing for moon song
i've been praying for the color purple
he said well
i think you should come and and audition
so i go to audition you know movie
people they make everything all secret
steven spielberg didn't want anybody
know he was doing color purple so on the
outside of the script it says moon song
but i know all the words by heart
so when i open the script i know this is
the color purple jesus this is the color
purple
yes
[Applause]
so i auditioned for the color purple i
can't even believe it they don't just
want me to be the water girl
or the best girl they are asking me do i
want a part in the movie oh that i'm
thinking prayer prayer works
[Applause]
prayer
works listen to this
three months pass three months is a long
time
i auditioned in february
march
april may comes i haven't heard anything
so i call reuben cannon
i say mr cannon
i'm sorry sir i haven't heard anything i
expected to hear something by now and
reuben cannon
african-american man
says to me
you don't call me
i call you
and i didn't call you
do you understand that i have real
actresses who have auditioned for this
part
real actresses and he tells me who just
left his office and i went well okay i'm
not getting that part
so i hang up the phone and i start
crying i can't believe that god has
played this trick on me i think
this is a trick so i decide that this is
because the fat has finally caught up
with me
the fat has finally caught up with me
and now i must get rid of the fat
in two weeks
i am going to go to a fat farm
and i'm going to lose
25 pounds
i'm gonna drink a lot of green juice
i'm gonna have some cleanses and
colonics
so i
i also
was trying to make peace with it
i said god i don't understand
i thought it was for me you ever had
that talk with god
i i thought it was for me i thought it
was for me
god you let me audition with somebody
named harpo
that's my name backwards jesus that was
a sign wasn't it a sign
and then three months pass and then then
reuben cannon says real actresses
have just left his office
so i start to pray on the track i'm out
on the track
at the fat farm
and i am running around at the track
at the fat farm
it starts to rain
you all know how that is
but i don't even care cause i am praying
to god to help me to let it go
help me let it go because now i've
become obsessed with it and it's now
controlling my life i start praying
running around the track
and i keep hearing this noise and i i
can't there's nobody on the track but me
and i'm running around the track
and i look around and it is my thighs
rubbing together
it's my thighs
my thighs are rubbing together
causing this thunderous
sound there's nobody on the track so
then i really start to cry
oh lord help me
help me let it go help me let it go help
me let it go god help me let it go
and you ever did this prayer where you
say okay lord don't come and let it go
then you get up and you go well i think
i still got a little bit of it
i did help me let it go
but i am not going to be able to see the
other actress in my part i won't be able
to see it won't be able to see color
purple just can't never see it the rest
of my life i won't be able to see it
so then i started
i don't know where it came from
i surrender all
i
surrender all
all
to thee my
blessed savior
i
surrender
all
i sang and i cried
i sang and i cried and i prayed some
more
until i could reach the point where not
only
not only will i be able to go to the
movie but i can bless
the other actress
i can bless her
i can say
i bless you i bless you i bless you with
this i surrender all
i
surrender all
o
to thee
my
blessed savior
i
[Music]
surrender all
and i tell you
in my greatest testimony
that the instant i laid that thing down
i'm telling you when i laid it down
when i laid it down and it didn't have
me anymore
it had no control over me anymore
i didn't feel anything about it anymore
when i let it go
when i intentionally surrendered it to
the power that was greater than i could
ever know the instant that happened
a woman comes running out of the
cafeteria
screaming oh free
is your name all free
for ten years nobody could pronounce my
name
i said yes she says somebody's on the
telephone for you he's saying named
spielberg
i get to the phone
he says i hear you're at a fat farm
i said no sir
this is a health retreat
he says i'd like to see you in my office
in california tomorrow this was in
wisconsin i was i'd like to see you in
my office
and if you lose a pound
you could lose this part
[Applause]
no
problem do i have
i'll have no problem not losing a pound
so honey i pack my bags
and i stopped at the dairy queen
[Applause]
i got three scoops just in case i'd lost
a half a pound
and the next day i was in steven
spielberg's office and he said you're
hired you're hired my television career
began unexpectedly
uh as you heard this morning i was in
the miss fire prevention contest
that was when i was 16 years old in
nashville tennessee
and you had the requirement of having to
have red hair in order to win
up until the year that i entered so they
were doing the question and answer
period because i knew i wasn't going to
win in the swimsuit competition so
during the question and answer period
the question came why young lady what
would you like to be when you grow up
and by the time they got to me all the
good answers were gone
so i had seen barbara walters on the
today show that morning so i answered
i would like to be a journalist
i would like to tell other people's
stories in a way that makes a difference
in their lives and the world
and as those words were coming out of my
mouth i went whoa this is pretty good
i would like to be a journalist i want
to make a difference
well i was on television by the time i
was 19 years old and in 1986 i launched
my own television show with a relentless
determination to succeed at first i was
nervous about the competition and then i
became my own competition
raising the bar every year pushing
pushing pushing myself as hard as i knew
sound familiar to anybody here
eventually we did make it to the top
and we stayed there for 25 years
the oprah winfrey show was number one in
our time slot for 21 years and i have to
tell you i became
pretty comfortable with that level of
success if you want more inspiration
morning videos they're not on this
channel anymore i have a dedicated
channel just for it it's right there
next to me go click it there continue to
believe and i'll see you there